how did you meet your co-founder and
decide to get going sure so I was
originally a computer science student
and I started a PhD you know my PhD was
an attempt to see if we could
automatically measure how good a
programmer is basically so put some true
a variety of sort of simulated code and
asked them to say what the output would
be and you know we had some really
interesting findings from our research
but I got bored I got bored 40 reasons
one as some of the findings were
slightly uncomfortable for some
universities because I was basically
saying that hey this person you're
saying is getting a 65% score I actually
don't think taking program because they
can't tell me what this code applets oh
and people don't want to hear it out
obviously just because they figured out
how to take exams well yes precisely
so typically the way and this is true
worldwide I think the way like people in
universities would mark a piece of code
is to Sarah will give them entry points
if they have a for loop and two points
if Tiffany of statement and people just
learned that off so like the phenomenon
is like that template based marking
encourages template based learning yeah
people like know what a solution should
look like but they have no idea what it
does right saying which like learning
off Latin or something so Sony I was
kind of that finding was became more and
more cultural for universities and as I
said hey I'd like to do some study on
your students here's my hypothesis
they're like no thanks so I started
writing a blog instead because that was
the alternative to publishing was just
write effective stuff and then I started
writing with design and usability
one day somebody commented on my blog
his name was own mccabe and he was
organizing this coffee morning and
Dublin City for like all they're like
you know the people who worked on the
Internet which is a small group and this
is like 2006 and and I went along and
I'm actually a funny story is I met own
for the first time Derek who I went out
to started into how much I also met my
wife for the first time of that really
that same wow yeah I fell you yeah it
was exactly a good day's work
yeah so I actually went to took a
different job with a consultancy and
then for one year we you know kind of
kept in touch and then one day email
they say hey I'm starting my own thing
do you wanna get involved so we started
working we had an agency called contrast
it was like a design agency and then we
were following the 37signals model we
wanted to have a side project that we'd
eventually pivot to so our side project
was a tool called exceptional
Ruby on Rails based error humbler and it
would like alert developers and notified
him hey this piece went wrong and here's
who was affected and that was like you
know so that was the normal trajectory
and then one day we were like we were
getting ready frustrated trying to
communicate with our users because we
had liked essence the thousands of
people using the product but the product
like was you know we was frequently
perform slowly or fall over and we were
we you know the state of the internet
back in 2010 it wasn't good like so the
infrastructure also narrator was no
strike video we if we wanted to mail all
of our paying customers to apologize for
some downtime it was like login to the
PayPal dashboard get an export of all
your subscriptions ruin not true some
pearl to extract the email addresses
import the email addresses into campaign
monitor MailChimp send out a
notification get all the replies and
like you know and all that like Auto
replies and all that [ __ ] back into your
own email you know resurrect your email
after like two errors of going true or
trying to fix all of that we had to do
every single time we wanted to say
anything to our customers that was the
norm so one day we had this little
message pop up in the bottom hand corner
bottom right hand corner of the product
saying hey we're sorry we were down
yesterday here's the changes you made
read our blog post and people and we saw
a lot of engagement of the blog post
much better memory so an email and then
we sort of started to riff from narrow a
lot of people could reply to us like
imagine talking to somebody wonder using
your product and letting them talk back
so in every started adding these little
bits of pieces of features another
iteration was like what if we could see
everyone who's read the message and
every new hasn't that became the basis
of what we call an active user mystic
who's using the product right now all of
this in 2017 is taken for granted but
this did not exist in 2011 and so we
said and then it was like what if we
could send a message to some people but
not all people what if we could send at
a specific time today we call that like
behavioral marketing automation but back
then we were just like this just seems
like it makes sense so I remember
distinctly reading one comment going
like I'm not actually much of a fan of
your product but this little chat thing
is amazing we're like maybe you should
all go build that
and like obviously we had been like
thinking that a lot but like it was like
the feedback we're getting people really
just push this and push this so
eventually we sell deception Eleni went
on to become a part of Rackspace and
then we had this little thing for
talking to users
we had a new problem here we had no
users so we have to go and build the
backend if you like so that we could
give it to other people so that we would
have our own customers so that we would
know because I was wondering if you were
just gonna steal all the users from
exceptional and move over because this
was maybe the most asked question for
you yes so I would the folks who
acquired exceptional they were actually
kind enough to use intercom to push one
last message out to sort of say hey
we're the new owners like we're here
we're great we're gonna love you for the
rest of your lives etc if you're curious
will happen to the old gang they're off
working on this thing called intercom go
check it out and I think it was like
July 1st 2011 we got to like the top of
hacker news for like you know intercom
like a cool new product or whatever and
I'm the engagement on that trash I still
read it and then it was just kinda that
was the first one where I was like a new
order people had this problem with him
and was that the hñ was that your first
push for sign ups yeah pretty much oh we
have so we had like a reasonable sort of
contact list from people who had used
our previous products people who we knew
from conferences or people who had read
our old blog so we had an audience of
sorts and we my job in nearly days it's
like literally mailing people every day
I mean like here's what intercom could
look like inside your product do you
want to give it a try one by one like
literally one by one we were onboarding
people if they said yes they jump on a
Skype call with our CTO Kieran he'd
walked in through the installation like
this is like this is what about at Oak
Park day I'm like like one by one we
were winning customers and then once we
felt we had a relatively smooth signup
flow we're like well let's tell the
world and see what happens okay because
you guys have made a giant content push
was that going on previously with the
other company yeah so and when we were
consultancy content was the way we would
try and like get attention so we could
attract the clients and then later on it
grow a user base for exceptional but
what intercom was very it was you know
we we knew we were good at it our
specific it was my job so I was like
right well the intercom you know today
we're a lot more polished in terms of
saying what were our she sounded like
but but back Danna was just like we need
cool startup folks to read this and then
if we can win their trust
then we'll be like hey train song yes
and that was like that was like - but
you know the right common question is
what was the basis of your content
strategy no mic right [ __ ] startup
people read and then try and tell them
about your product every now and then
that was like and that was what we did I
wrote I think I wrote 93 of the first
100 posts and I was all like here's a
girl user base here's how you should
think about funneling here's how you
should name your product it was just
anything that we felt we had any a bit
of expertise and we'd like sort of write
a post or and and every now and then
we'd be like oh here's something else be
out at the intercom yeah because this is
um that's a critical understanding that
we could blow right past so many people
in their content just try and do sales
pitches over and over and it never works
and they can't figure out why yeah it's
it's my number like basically you're
totally correct
a lot of people attempt at content
marketing is I want intercoms user base
so they blog so I just need to write
about my product all the time whereas we
actually took it very much like it's
content first marketing second right you
know so it's a gas the content has to be
good yeah so the advice I'd give people
is usually like think about who your
actual and target user is and think of
all the problems in their life that you
can help them with and then try to help
them as much as you can
mm-hmm and then every now and hopefully
your if your ideally aligned your
product also solves one of their
problems from an intercom it's usually
like do you want to grow your web app or
you want to grow your user base we can
do that but we'll but we know to get
your attention we have to plant many
seeds so we'll talk about design we'll
talk about product we'll talk about
product strategy we'll talk about like
you know tech news whatever makes sense
to us we'll talk about as long as it the
criteria we have is generally it should
be like timeless content that should
always be roughly true and and that's
how we mean we have like you know very
very big user a readership of our blog
today and it's one of our you know it is
our dominant traffic source but a we you
know that wasn't true for the first 100
posts well I was wondering were you
punching above your weight at that time
did it feel weird writing these kind of
authoritative posts so I think um I
definitely didn't did not feel weird I
think like the reason I would say I felt
confident to do it is because we it was
never I was never trying to say like
here's how you you know like a
you know scale of $100,000,000 arrow
company whatever and I hate when people
try to do that we were always talking
about like you know all of our
experiences were based on the two
products we had on intercom an
exceptional and it was like the lessons
that we had learned so I I was always
careful to kind of qualify like hey like
we're out six thousand active users we
were at zero four months ago I can talk
to you about to zero to sixty know
something I think that's relatively safe
yeah so and then like the the areas
where maybe it was you know slightly
more if we talked about broadening or
say how to name your company right or
like how to think about your product
vision yeah there are definitely better
people than you and if you put you know
if I can writing these posts so we're
watching s do you wanna say at that time
did you consider yourself a strategist
no no I consider myself like a startup
person if you don't mean like as you
were CS undergrad right yeah yeah yeah
for sure okay see were you the CTO no no
so is computer science undergrad [ __ ]
all of the founders study computer
science but our CEO and I moved into
moved into design as our career I was a
UX designer you know usability testing
interaction design that sort of stuff
own was a primarily a visual designer
and then we had at to our to order two
engineers like person who built the
front end of intercom like their little
messenger piece and then our CTO
basically owned the rest okay gotcha
because I was curious about what your
role has been throughout the process
like how was it shifted and we talked
before you were on camera like it's
already shifting again mmm it will
always just I you know I do kind of go
to wherever the biggest problem that I
think I can help what is that's kind of
what usually attracts me it's like you
know I want to intercom to be a world
class company and wherever I see areas
where I think I can help level up I'll
jump in into very early days I worked
you know my I'd sort of tree jobs like
work without on kind of company vision
strategy that sort of stuff I work with
Karen and David on what the rush you
building day today
and then basically talk to users and you
know try and help people find out about
intercoms and I was blogging that was a
he always used to do webinars or like
you know 7 p.m. in the evening and
movement people over here I just do like
live here let me talk to you but
anything to do with the product like it
was anywhere I was needed but in the
early days it was very much
like was working on what we're building
and then trying to tell people about us
and then as we grew we brought in like
more senior product folk and then yeah
and then at some point maybe around 25
people I was a great product looks like
it's in a good place
okay what's the next biggest thing and
what turns out he had no customer
support at this time like I was also
doing a but if Donnelly had maybe one or
two people so so I jumped on customer
support I worked with a Jeff is their
director of support still today and
built that team and his other teams that
came along since then we had maybe like
people up so it's the next thing it's a
recruiting or the next thing and then
about two years ago it was marketing so
so you know we've kind of got through a
clinic we think intercom was definitely
the product have we gone right price we
would we looked at I kind of refined our
ideas about like how we bring it to
market how we describe it yeah explain
what it is what's our relationship with
the media how do we pay for advertising
and all that sort of stuff so that's
what I've been working on for two years
and and as he said they'll you know
it'll be future problems I'm sure but
it's so cool because so rarely founders
shift roles in in like entirely separate
categories right it's very common when
you start a company to like start doing
everything and then focus but to shift
roles between groups is different how do
you learn those skills yeah I that is a
good question I do agree it's not like
it's not the default thing usually you
find your corner and you stay in it like
for a very good reason that's what
you're gonna um I think like two years
ago I was when I was starting a
marketing I felt a little intimidated
because marketing itself it's not really
am like there's no real like marketing
101 sort of thing there's no like
marketing for dummies there's no like
there's no like pickaxe book for
marketing you know well it's less
quantifiable than like yeah just how it
runs or this code doesn't run precise
yeah and you can emit sound if I said
here named Saudi is good at marketing
and you're not allowed to Apple like
everyone's opinion is kind of different
right so so I'm like I'm frankly like
marketers don't really like write many
articles about how to think about things
or any structure teams or you know I've
talked to maybe 50 different VPS in
marketing at this point of a head of
marketing organ structure and they're
all different like very like not just
different as a newbie you put one person
a book substantively different like even
like in terms of like some of those
Brian designers inside some of these
headsets and moments Communications
reports to CEO some of the reports to a
part of marketing you know
all of that's different so I did find it
quite intimidating early on and more so
than the other areas where I felt
there's a lot of literature and there's
a lot of best practices in marketing it
was a challenge and I the way I actually
kind of learned was like I did get
connected to great companies and
basically sit and learn and absorb and
see what worked and what didn't and then
I wouldn't say like I kicked ass in
marketing an intercom writer I've made
plenty of mistakes there as well
fundamentally based and misunderstanding
what roles will work what types of
people will work what approaches will
work so with their husband you know I
definitely know a lot more today and I
feel like today I'd feel justified in
applying for a marketing job somewhere
we're writing a marketing blog post yeah
for sure yeah but but two years ago I
you know I was aware of two things I was
aware died like you know we we tried
hiring marketers and we hadn't worked
out well so I figured at the very least
if I can learn enough to know what good
looks like that'd be great you know were
there a couple rules that you've kind of
maybe learned just through experience
over the past couple years that you
could share about rules of marketing
yeah I guess um there's definitely like
principles I've just picked up over time
one is like the you know the general
narrative about marketing is people will
tell you well the engineers approach to
marketing is like we're gonna harvest a
marketer and they're gonna find a key
words that are KLTV positive that is the
customer boss is asking the LTV and
we're gonna dump all of our 50 million
dollars into that and it's gonna spit
out hundred million dollars I'm like
basically that never happens right that
I really like someone's like I'm sorry
Dez I have one case it never happens
like for all intents and purposes and
and so I think like you know whenever
you have someone promising it out it's
usually absolute horseshit
then the next I guess the let me just
take like say so I'm sorry from dialect
the next piece I think is M
understanding how people buy your
product is more important than selling
your product if you know what I mean so
one big eye-opener from you is that like
some people come shopping for intercom
some people come shopping for a chat
widget on our website right so we become
looking for a solution to their growth
challenges all right and they're all
actually looking for intercom and what I
mean is like you are variously
of abstraction at various ways people
can buy your product so like I think a
lot of times companies get sucked into
selling apart one particular way yeah
and maybe they like you know maybe they
pick one of those things I'm like we are
you know live chat it's like yes your
live chat and some people know that they
need life chalice and they've gone to
the doctors they've gone the diagnosis
life we need live chat they talk to
their friend and they're like so you so
you have this brand one which is like
your friend says install an intercom
yeah then you have this like maybe you
know you've changed market leaders okay
we need live chat on our site that
worked in the old place okay now you're
shopping for live chat so we need to be
in that shopping for live chat then we
have people who are like hey I've just
joined a new company and one of the
challenges is actually we're not
converting leads in our homepage now at
this point like it should install
Optimizely should install intercom
should they redesign our homepage should
they hire a better designer we're now in
a much bigger fight but we still need to
put our hand up and say hey that's
actually a business problem we can
affect - so a so I think one of the big
lessons for us in their home it's been
like learning to be able to like to put
our hand up in all of those different
shopping journeys so that was like one
whenever I speak to other people who
maybe like earlier on in the marketing
career and they're looking for guidance
typically what they find is like you
know enter Google advertising they're
bidding on their own company name and
I'm like that's cool but that's actually
not worth it you know that's not what
people are shopping for well it's a
challenge that we have a YC you know
like for people in the tech industry who
know they want to do an accelerator like
the likelihood that they know YC is
pretty high and we can convince them to
do I see possibly then there are other
people that are have no idea what a
start-up is you have this vague notion
and we have to speak to them as well
yeah and so what strategies do you guys
use to appeal to that type of person or
each of those people without alienating
the others yes so and this is this is
kind of a core of what we how we think
about it so so when you have somebody
who say is you know obviously YC has a
broader yeah like so so some people just
shop for YC and and maybe maybe you're
so dominant you don't even need to bid
on that because they're gonna find you
anyway but also like you know in some
sense you know there is no substitute
right
as you take a step back you're like some
people just want the money right answer
my car I'll take Y C I'll take tech
stairs I'll take 500 startups whatever
right and now you're into an actual
brand war now the question is should you
bid on 500 startups the keyword right
and should you should you try and say we
are better than here's why we are better
than them if you're shopping for both
come check this at right that's like the
sort of too competitive angle to
marketing right and and if you can pull
that off you now get to like compete for
all the superset of the traffic not just
the YC shoppers anymore and then you
have two people who like who have a
start-up and they don't know if they
want money or not in which case no these
people aren't googling right they're not
going you know hypothetically if I was
to start a sign of what I want you know
exactly do that long yeah you'd be the
only person bidding on it that'd be you
testing it so like this is so dynamic
the basically what happens is like the
amount the size of the is getting bigger
each time right there are more people
who are thinking about starting a
start-up than there are people looking
for YC today yeah so but at the same
time like your likelihood of conversion
is going down right is in some looking
for YC is gonna convert somebody who's
like thinking about taking incubator
money they might knock over your pitch
needs to be more all-inclusive at this
sort of far side so you can't you can't
start if I'm saying hey I'm thinking
about taking some incubator money you
can't start with well twelve weeks
you're gonna have dinners with founders
we had Joel Spolsky and last you know
you I need to be like whoa talk to you
about the concept of incubation well you
know get me buying that thing first and
then I'll learn what your best right so
so for intercom like what that looks
like is we need to convince you that you
should care about your customers right
if you care about your customers and you
care about the value of a customer
relationship and we can get people on
board with that you know they're more
like oK we've built one bridge the next
bridge would like to talk to you about
is why messaging is a great way to build
a relationship so well none of these
pitches in to individually convert right
they're all like you this is where
people buy quite a [ __ ] you right - [ __ ]
des and I'm like so like so you have
like so you you write a whole piece
that's a few svet my messaging is the
future I'm messaging your customers it's
important to look okay so I get the
relationships are important I get that
messaging builds relationships I'm like
okay cool now do you get no they talked
about intercoms messaging and in our
philosophy to mastering
and you see you have sort of this like
cascading series of like thought
leadership you sort of style ideas that
bring you from in our world like I you
know I would like to grow a big user
base yeah all the way true - I need
intercom yesterday and in your world it
might be like I'm curious about
incubator cash oh and you want to catch
them at that point and maybe that blog
post you write there is like how do you
think about early financing or maybe
it's like why you should move to the
valley or you know whatever it is and
you want to catch them at that point and
then you can walk them then the logical
path where like this obviously know what
a choice won't earth would you go oh I
see right and that's a you know that's
the actual approach that we've you know
we've played at intercom and I like
retrospectively I can tell you Daffy has
been her content marketing strategy but
we didn't thinking wasn't that crisp
register no and are you tracking someone
throughout this journey kind of not
we're not doing a great job and I've had
to be honest we will get there yeah
we've just made some good new hires in
marketing he'll kind of improve dot sort
of side of things but we do know like
yes we can see that we matter of repeat
wages we have and we can see the most
popular articles and we can see the
Articles that convert most now like this
is exactly where like it may be slightly
more fisher-price approach to marketing
would be like hey yes I've noticed that
the piece about intercoms new messenger
converts a lot why don't you write a lot
more of those posts and it doesn't
actually work that way right you have to
you have to do two warm-ups to get them
to their you know so I think that's like
that's the piece that people don't
necessarily get like in general the
marketing world is one where you move
from like this is really hard to
attribute and it costs a lot of money
down to like hey we spent seven cent and
I kicked ass right but that whole thing
is a spectrum and you have to be willing
to do the unattributable things and let
them you know to kind of you know grow
awareness whatever and then on the far
side yes the attributable stuff which
looks really really successful works but
if you only do that everything suffers
so one example I have a friend who like
who basically he ran like paid marketing
for a very very big sort of sports
gambling for him
and he kicked ass one year here on all
campaigns phenomenally well
CEO looks at like sort of the brand
spend and looks at the online digital
attributable span and CEO says hmm I'm
gonna give you all the budget because
you're doing is performant so next year
what happens so he's got all the budget
per Bron person's got nothing so you go
absolutely batshit heavy on like
spending every account but all your
conversion rates are dropping you're not
yeah and it turns out that your
conversion rates are dropping because
you don't have the same brawn
penetration that you did yeah and I'm
like this is why I like you need to like
think about this think holistically you
need to ask yourself are we building the
brand are we creating the right brand
resonance and relevance that we can cash
in on cashing in on I don't want to say
it's easier to absolute expertise but it
sits on a platform of work that has to
be done before it the only exception is
when you've got like a fast-moving
consumer good right like if you're like
selling share our heads on Facebook or
summat that looks like just target
people who say the word share or hit
them hard you know we don't need to like
you know we don't need to create this
whole big sort of a movement around
sharing people already share it you know
but yeah most of us is best specifically
in our industry we're not selling fast
moving to earth and we're not selling
necessarily obvious things either like
it's not a given that you have to
install like a podcast plugin or a thing
I was literally dealing with this
morning before we met up there's an
issue with one of the audio files and a
podcast I'm editing right and I don't
know the word for what's going wrong
with it I know there must be some effect
that I can apply to fix it but I don't
even do it [ __ ] worth it right and
I'm sure that's the case intercom yeah
yeah and so like we have to figure out
what the synonyms are totally people
don't know they need it yet right like
it yeah and yes precisely on a donor
marketing principle it's a it's like you
you can't sell somebody on the solution
until they've bought the problem right
so like me trying to pitch you on like
the audio worker or whatever the hell it
is you need until you have that problem
you're not even you don't give a [ __ ]
right this is like so like so finding
those moments this really is a really
important challenge as well I'm like as
you said like this synonym is just
casting a wide net so it's like ten ways
to describe a problem for like intercom
it could be like retention is suffering
or a Kobe like we need to accelerate
user growth or it's like how do we
maintain user growth through its
how do i influence customer engagement
they're all actually looking for the
same thing which might be like I want to
speak to my users but at specific times
to get them to take the right action so
that they can move forward they're all
shopping for the exact same thing but
they have a million different ways to
describe it and we need to be there and
put our hand up for every single one of
those I'm not just I point them to this
is your mistake people make pointing
that okay all right so I got the bid
term I'm gonna point them at that
homepage that doesn't work because if
someone says I want to onboard my users
better because I'm boarding conversion
rates are per and we're like yet we can
bid on all that we know we're good at
all that but if we point you to intercom
calm we're gonna say we're an all-in-one
marketing platform where our mission is
to make my place is persuade I'm sorry I
thought I was on to something there you
know we actually need to be like you
want to onboard you're in the right
place yeah I'm like and at that point
intercom isn't actually the big deal
we're just like let's just keep the
message about onboarding here let me
hold your hand and walk you through how
we're gonna help you with the onboarding
problem and if you break okay and
they've randomly be like oh by the way
this holding intercom yeah that's how
that works
so a lot of people wanted you to talk
about product how do you think about all
this content marketing effort in the
context of you know your product
shifting and evolving over time like how
do you merge those two things if you
know intercom is known for one thing
yeah and you have this whole history and
all this SEO around that when your
product starts shifting how do you think
about it so as long as you know
basically a you know every product I've
often said like you know product and
marketing and code and design are all
like they're all renderings of the same
core idea looks so like so to give an
example one core idea intercom it's like
sending the right message to the right
person at the right time in the right
place and and we have Ruby code that
does that you know we have a designed
screen called the campaign editor that
does that and I have a blog post that
does this and I have a whole conference
talk that I do this as well right
they're all carrying the same message in
different ideas so at the core of every
one of our products educate respond and
engage we have these like core ideas and
we have loads of different ways to sort
of talk about them case studies and how
they help why it matters what's the big
vision for them each is and and as we've
evolved our products we've had to like
bring more ideas into the fold the at
the very core like intercom we're about
making internet business personal so as
we can never bring something in that is
the opposite of that right but a but we
can certainly have a collection of ideas
that we can represent so when we bring
so we launch new product in December of
last year
I called educate and it was basically
it's our take on a knowledge base for
like basically offering proactively
offering an educational content to your
customers and what that meant was I you
know I sit down with my team we work
very well we need to work out what are
the core ideas here and write events
what can we do in terms of events
content what we're gonna do
books are we gonna do books how we gonna
get this in a podcast once it's gonna
one of the landing pages for us what are
all the different ways people bid on
this you know media how are we gonna
talk to the press about this you know
and you're kind of looking for like
everyone here's the core idea you're all
welcome to take your own lens or your
own flavor of it but we all need to push
on this idea and so the bad things
happen I think when either your product
your sorry your product and your
marketing are out of sync so isn't Karen
peacock who's our CEO she always says
build what you sell sell what you build
if you're not doing both of those things
you're in [ __ ] trouble basically
right
but similarly I think so that that's the
first challenges if we're selling
onboarding and you think you're building
like auto mailing we're in trouble right
and then similarly the piece that like
that I think a lot of startups and we've
had to like fight to get this right as
making sure to your brand is also
resonant with the same ideas like uh you
know so you can't you know I often think
of you know Michelin the people who do
Michelin star restaurant yeah you know
it's a tire company I do yeah so like I
often like that's like you know
orthogonal bronze in another way so you
know and no one finishes your meal goes
boom gonna buy some tires you know like
like I do worry I see a lot of startups
like specific people who folks who try
to copy say something like say stripes
Brant and we want to be cool with
developers - yeah Rick that's great but
you're selling an online writing up
developers aren't your thing you know it
okay and what they have this really cool
tech blog and right but that's literally
it's not against what you're doing but
it's just totally raw it's just like it
just it also happens to happen at the
same time right it's not helping you at
all right well how do you think about
product in that way then because
obviously you guys are a big company now
you could release a ton of products yes
how do you figure out like what's going
to rest
with your customers in your brand so at
the very very start we've kind of we set
our stall out to say we're our mission
is to make Internet business personal
right so so that's a very core anytime
we have to like make a decision about
whether or not we do a product we ask
ourselves does this make business more
personal in the Internet right and so
you can sort of say like would we
release the tool that made it easy to
spam people you never talked to you
before well no because that's that's
that's totally opposite would we release
a tool that lets you stream soccer live
to your mobile phone no because I said
you don't read that in an interview
though but like is it so like that's
kind of our core sort of guardrail for
like the product is just basically it
does it do that and then went in there
like then we have other like sort of you
know let's say rubrics for like what's
the my what's the next most important
way we could tackle the impersonality of
digital business right and so we kind of
moved to like that but and you know the
you know every change we make in product
has to trigger changes in product
marketing you know like design you know
brand content marketing sales etc yeah
and so you do have to have this sort of
like inside-out sort of thing where like
at the very core we decide all right
we're now also gonna you know do like
push notifications all right well why
are they personal okay well let's expand
from there all right and the house it
has to bleep out into everything what it
was your product your marketing and your
brawn to get out of sync and that's when
bad things happen and we really truly
we've talked about this in the context
of hiring and growth right because you'd
like you become out of sync and then it
kind of expands or rather goes
exponentially yes
if you how to start hiring the wrong
people yeah totally yeah it's so easy
too
yeah the point I make exactly in a sort
of hiring it's like if you hire one
person who's not on the same page area
and you let them hire people they're
gonna hire more people in the same page
and any the whole wings of the company
working against you and they in bad ways
and they don't think you're being
malicious yes they do they think they're
helping but you know sometimes they can
be doing these after wrong team but more
often they're just doing something
that's literally not helping it's not
hurting but it's just it's you know they
may as well I cannot be doing they're
just not working yeah whatever
playing games how do you guard against
that alignment is like I think it's like
doing it so we had a big event here two
nights ago inside intercom I'm it's like
our blog on terror we had like I said
people and one of the talks I was made a
gay if it was all about like keeping
people aligned I think like basically
like the thing was that you know that
when companies go through these really
fast great periods there's a few things
that always always get left behind
yeah one of them is like new hire
onboarding it's like person number five
joining a four person company has like
full access to everyone and basically
absolute immersion therapy right I
already learned everything by osmosis
person number 66 joining a 65 person
company gets access to treat people each
of whom have been there less than a year
right it's not the same thing
no but almost always no one's designed
is any differently so they're just like
oh well you know so the logical
conclusion is that the company goes off
course so we invested him like we made
versions of this mistake you know quite
a lot in the early days yeah and today
we obsess over new hard on boarding like
when I leave here I'll be headed back to
Dublin like Tuesday morning like that's
all I'm doing is just meeting people in
that even though like what are we doing
you know what are we actually doing here
why are we doing why do we care what are
the problems faced why is the matter to
us how do we do it like how do we
actually work how does work happen that
intercom in certain practical terms this
means a one-on-one meeting with you just
talking yeah it starts it'll be a
combination of so first and so it's a
bunch of new hires it'll be a
presentation for me a bit like walking
show up see everything and then then it
will be one normal meetings and then
it'll be you know we'll we'll take it
from there you know because they're not
all reporting to me in this case so
they'll be with their manager to kind of
keep that going but it's them like I
would say that I still believe that
we're probably not even doing enough
like but I think most companies don't do
enough like you know they don't really
don't think about what's the experience
of being person number 397 or your
company yeah and then they are somehow
shocked and like I can't believe a
thought it was okay to ship down you're
like look
show me the guardrails that stopped her
like you know how on earth were they
supposed to work that out yeah
absolutely and in the
you can't like really blame them I mean
we do it we need to do a better job here
as well Andy cook asked a question
related to this so in addition to hiring
what has been the biggest challenge with
scaling the organization yeah I guess
like there's a few ones that have you
know they're probably more typical but
like when you eventually your end up
hiring it area so you don't understand
well Jana on your best bet at that point
is to kind of like go find somebody who
you think is doing a good job and but
like you you know you're still you know
it's still a version of the same flawed
logic which is I think I can work this
out you know write a blog post about
this so they probably know it all right
like you know it's just some version of
that and it's very easy when you're
dipping your toes in areas that you
really don't understand to basically be
bullshitted um I think specifically in
marketing and sales and this is more
common marketers and sales people are
good at marketing to you and selling
with you so if you've never hired a
sales person before don't be shocked if
the first person to come see you sells
you on the roll like that's you know you
know that you know it's obvious in
hindsight sort of thing for them I think
like you know it's genuinely tough to
break outside of a sort of your own area
of expertise and hire well there but
lucky you will learn it but it's just
it's it takes longer and you don't get
the same immersion that you did from
like say studying computer science or
some other so that's definitely one I
think we probably more than other
companies we started with two offices so
in some sense we never had to deal with
you know with the like oh my god there
were two offices we have we were always
- yeah but that's been a challenge like
working out like the right head counts
in the right places we now have four
offices were in like Dublin London San
Francisco and Chicago and we're sort of
spread and it makes some something's
really tricky like today we had like a
Show and Tell sort of thing every
wherever and everyone who works on any
sort of aspect anyone who's running the
show basically they kick toss their
clothes their tails the ability right
piece of product or whatever they all
line up to present but like
orchestrating that is so hard across all
the time zones across all the offices
it's just it's it's far from easy and
you have to do these sort of sort of
little rituals to keep the whole company
on the same page but maintaining that is
it's her
it was hard for us in racer today we can
spend a lot of money on video
conferencing and I thought put that but
early on it was roughly do you spend
money like flying people around to hang
out with each other
mm-hm you do like any kind of everyone
comes together we have we haven't done a
sort of all company All Hands I think in
like two and a half three years but we
definitely do like versions of it so any
team that's distributed will will always
come together once once to four times a
year depending on the type of team okay
then like leadership level and exactly
what we do like think six times zero
smells like this versions I would like
for for me what that means is if I get
on flight number II I one four seven
everyone knows me because which is never
like you know you don't want to be like
on Foursquare like the mayor of the
lounges in the airports and all that
like c'est la vie what hasn't worked out
what's been really hard for you
personally I think marketing as being
tough just still five really struggled
with ISM hiring senior leaders in a
function when you don't understand it
well is tough it's if it's a big
challenge
on it and they're never bad people like
they're always at this when you're when
you're going shopping for like directors
and senior directors and VPS you're only
really talking to accomplished people
hmm
so like it's not like you know it's not
like you get them in and it turns out
they can't they don't know how to write
code or something like it's like it's
very much the feedback period to order
and after strategy is correct for the
company can be six months to a year
which is you know which is lada all
right the impact if they're going the
wrong direction can be negative critic
it because you have to bet on them which
means you have to like empower them to
hire and pair them to do everything that
you need to do and perform spend the
budget etc yeah and then you get to find
out like in quite a while if all this
pays back and so I think like it's the
piece that's hard I actually don't think
I've made that money mistakes per se but
I've just paid quite an emotional attack
so it's just kind of a great degree of
like fear and anxiety in the recruiting
process and then and then like I guess
I'm honestly post post hire like I'm
like well like did you know I need to do
everything I can to make this a success
so I mean that's genuinely like that's
something I've struggled with learning a
lot of people stuff has been hard like
so learning had like ensure that we
actually have a good
Seifer say performance monitoring I
think those conversations and even on
podcast like this it's easier for me to
not talk about stuff but like yes of
course companies have to fire people and
do all sorts of elderly yeah no one ever
wants to hear it of course but like I
think you know getting to a place where
you understand that these things should
be a openly discussed in and like and
you know professional conversations by
people who know what they're doing and
getting there like genuine I think every
start with talked it takes them way too
long mm-hmm and I ain't you know if I
was to do it all again of course you'd
be more familiar but like but I think
yeah you know there's a lot of obvious
pitfalls and and yet I don't think you
necessarily preempt every mistake hmm as
in even if I told somebody he was just
starting the first sort of here's
everything I know but it's like it's
some of its kind of like yeah that
doesn't apply to me and they're not
gonna you know yeah you know it's it's
back to that point I saying earlier like
you're not gonna buy the solution until
you've bought the problem and you know
I'm trying to I'm trying to force-feed
them like you know yeah
were there any books or anything cuz I
feel similarly like so many people have
given me advice and I've had to fall
into the hole myself before I could
really learn it but were there any you
know books or podcasts that really
helped you figure out how to manage
people better rounds has a book called
monitoring humans and I thought that was
it's written entirely in story form so
it's not it's not preachy it's not like
it's not like here's like you know it's
it's very much like here's stories from
his time now I'm sure they're either
fake or embellished or modified to
protect the innocent um but uh but it's
written in a very sort of conversational
tone where it kind of reminds me of the
hard thing about hard things with Ben
Harmon but like it's every story
they're almost like fortune cookies when
you take per second of [ __ ] I have been
in that situation or where I put
somebody in that situation or I was daca
and I think like it's a great book for
that reason I think at the very least
what it does what I see it do like a
first-time managers is it opens their
eyes to the idea that there's more going
on to managing than just being really
good at engineering you know like they
realized as an actual hold craft here
that they need to perfect to be to take
the next steps in your career and I
think it's a great book for that but
it's also a book II ain't the third time
you read it you probably start picking
up better lesson
than you did the first time mmm okay and
so just to shift gears back to the
product yeah if someone is just getting
started out like what do you advise them
on thinking about products just framing
the entire company yeah where do you
have them start I guess like I've always
sort of said like startups need a strong
vision so you do I'm like it sounds
fluffy unknown you know people want to
start writing code on day one for them
there's a sense that you need to have a
good strong sense of purpose for your
company and that it's so important for
hiring and further keeping a trend line
and stuff as well you need time like to
have everyone in the same page you need
a page you know so I think like often
times I think people start maybe two or
three steps down the path that it might
say like you know a lot of people email
themselves to dues I'm gonna fix that
and I'm like okay I and I can see how
you might have had a brilliant idea like
specifically around that but it's kind
of like what's the bigger landscape that
this sits in like are you trying to
change productivity you know what's your
what do you believe the productivity
that no one else believes oh I believe
it shouldn't be siloed or I believe it
should be a part of everyday life or I
believe that you shouldn't be able to
take on more than one thing at a time or
it remark okay well so that so we're
gonna form the basis of a philosophy for
you and your problem domain and then
we're then we'll work out what pieces do
you think you can uniquely product if I
if you're not I mean like you know in
program that program and you know codify
and then that will form the basis of
your product and maybe that happens to
look like your tool that looks like an
email comment but it's actually to do
list maybe and but like let's take a
step back first so that's kind of the
first conversation I try to have is kind
of like let's just appraise the whole
environment here and work out what
unique thing are you saying I'm like
when people pitch me like a new weather
app or whatever I'm like but like what's
your belief about wetter and I'd like
one I just think they all look OB and
I'm like okay so you believe that
beautiful wetter will do what you're
like I just like design my tops so like
maybe you shouldn't be raising around
so that that's the kind of like the
based platform denim yeah
the next piece I would say that people
is like you have to find you be really
wary of solving a small rare problem you
can solve a big problem you can solve a
rare problem sorry you can solve a small
problem
fine a rare problem fine but small and
rare is just it's it's never works I've
never and these products can be effing
beautiful right but what I mean by this
is that basically problems your life
right are big or small okay a big
problem might be like hey me and seven
of my friends want to book a group
holiday to Alaska and we have to do
blood by gar and this is a whole big
project I'm only gonna do it once a year
but it's a big enough thing okay fine
you could probably build a product
around on and probably make some money
because there's enough value it's a big
enough problem in your life that if we
can fix it you'll pay some money or we
will take some commission or something
right then so that's the size spectrum
then this thing isn't happening every
year or thinks it up in every day and
and the things that happen every day
typically like you'll have a lot of
engagement so it Department will bury
its way into your life however if you're
something that no one really cares with
it often sorry nobody cares about and
they don't have that problem that often
and let's say over the last two years -
is a large amount of apps that are all
no default there was saying you know -
I'm Marc Andreessen splits up his tweets
will help you do that and they designed
these like typographically stunning
products as in anyone who looks at your
blog yes that is a beautiful product
it's a perfect piece of product it
solves a very rare problem the data is
very small in nature and that's the
extreme case but there are versions of
this like you can imagine a loads of b2b
things that happen occasionally and not
not that big a deal and then on the
other extreme you've got the problems
that occur all the time and are pretty
big mm-hmm
workplace communication you know
charging your customers money talking to
your customers right it's like big
problem on you know you do it every all
the time they're like the places where
like the stock stripes and intercoms
whatever can play like it's like it
creates that sort of you know no one
ever you know no one ever you know
threatens to like idly like you know I
guess we're going to change platform
provider or whatever
they're locked in yeah and so like I you
know that's the next piece which is I
think people can and you know intercom
might have been responsible for the Miss
I think we defied products and watch the
people just thought if you have a great
product that's it the product itself
will match with a problem that's great
products much problems does it much with
a big problem or a frequent problem or
ideally a big freedom problem that's the
next big test I think a lot of startups
fall down there when they're like oh we
sync your Facebook to your Instagram and
we can do X Y and then it spits out a
Shopify app I'm like yeah I I just don't
see it being a problem that often in
someone's life so so that's the kind of
the next waved and disorder like little
philosophies that say isn't like if
you're gonna charge it not a lot of
money it needs to be self-serve and it
needs to be entirely frictionless for
the users and and I see a lot of people
get what I call it fake traction where
like the handheld a lot of early
customers like doing they're like the YC
Fame yeah Holle awesome install type
thing but they actually don't have a
bridge towards a world where word count
where that isn't necessary and I'm
trying to say like if you're gonna spend
30 minutes talking to every single
customer needs install and you've no
bigger picture as to how you're not
going to be necessary you need to be
charging more than $9 a month yeah and
and and that's just you know it sounds
obvious but I you'll find a lot of
people like whoever very high let's call
it adjusted customer acquisition cost
right when you factor in the founder
involvement a lot they have a high CAC
and they literally have no no plan to
get away from it and yet they have
traction as they can point to like the 9
grand a month to make working yeah yeah
exactly but it's just it's not scalable
you know that's another sort of
dangerous area I feel is that people
from another example this might be like
my product kind of good but I actually
layer in a lot of free consulting time
with me right so like this is like hey
I've built a way to you know
automatically email your customers and
and as part of the service I'm gonna
could jump in and write all your emails
and I'm like well that's what people are
buying you your consultant right now I'm
not a software provider I'm like that's
not how it works
it's dangerous yeah what about markets
that are growing so you like something
entirely new mm-hmm how do you think
about that in the context so you know
frequency rare
all big yeah so I think you know it's
it's I wouldn't say essential but it's
really really useful if you're selling
into a growing market but everything I
still said still needs to apply right so
like the addressable market is is kind
of one variable in the formula here but
ultimately like if it's a small rare
problem it's still like you could have a
billion people in the in addressable
market it's still the fact that small
and rarest it means that they're very
one inclined to pay any real money
because like the fact that dairy in a
market doesn't change in which one he
did have right and so so that's one
problem you're not there and then the
usual knee-jerk reaction of how we're
gonna get out of this is oh well we
won't charge users will go with ads
instead and I'm like put the ads won't
work because if it's a rare problem
they're not gonna launch yet but we're
not gonna Vizio page 11 so you don't
have the engagement to get the eyeballs
to get the actual like the revenue for
your publishers so I'm or for your
advertisers so like you know it you know
in some sense you you know it is you
know in some abstract sense possible to
have a product that all of the world
uses like seven billion people use but
if they actually don't care about it at
all it's not not important in their
lives they could take it or leave it and
on top of that they can take it or leave
it once a year when the actual problem
occurs it's just not gonna work you know
they're never gonna pay you enough yeah
so there were a couple questions about
intercoms specifically in your future
goals so what are so Fozzie Bear on
Twitter s what are your top two growth
initiatives for intercom in the next two
years so I have to like you know I'd
love to ask crossly but exactly what the
definition of a growth initiative is I
guess like the things I'm keen to do
over the next two years as get our
marketing to a place where we were
comfortable being slightly more direct I
think we've done a really good job from
okay so on leadership perspective of
getting the attention of a lot of people
who should use this b2b and b2c and but
I think we need to learn to be more
direct and upfront about say the ORA y
of intercom I think that's an area where
we have a lot of maturing to do the
intercom helps all sorts of businesses
you know deliver like multi-million
dollar results but we never tell anyone
that we're telling people like you
should love your users and treat them
really well and good things will happen
to your business and that works true
it's true
right but like you know I think at some
point as you move up through the market
you're you the onus is on you to say
basically businesses at some scale care
about two things how much money they
spend then how much money they make
yeah so when you try to pitch them
something they just say hey here's my
two numbers which one of these are you
changing and I think you know when we
show up we're like well if you love your
users you're gonna stick or indirect Shh
don't care about any of us are you going
to make me money or save me money and we
need to get better at answering that
question and we need to have better
evidence to answer that question we need
to surface more case studies and we we
have all the material we just need to be
more intentional I think about being
upfront about that volume so that's one
whole area that I'm quite invested in
and the second one for me is I'm the
intercom brand is quite big we had like
you know a 1200 people show up to our
event here on Wednesday we felt like six
thousand people attend retur we have
like you know obviously a widely popular
podcast books blogs etc but I you know a
piece I'm keen to do is I kind of
connect the dots a little bit better
between like intercom the the content
phenomenon of sorts and inator common
software and and that's so that's
something else I'll be working on I
don't know if I qualifies as a growth in
it's a Challenger we have to reassure
you have things like HN podcasts you
have our YouTube channel and I was just
talking to Michael Seibel yesterday like
you know where we've doubled our YouTube
channel in like six months and that's
awesome how many of those people know it
YC is it actually works exactly no I'm
like we have that like um you know I
think a lot of brands get stuck in this
sort of ambiguous place where like
people know them and love them but when
it comes to shopping for software or
shopping for incubators they just don't
see them in that way you know and I
think that's a that's a challenge like
you know as in you might could well but
I would hope it's not but it could well
be the case that there are like hundreds
of thousands of people who really know
who I see but they when they go shopping
for the incubator they'd rather go to
their local incubator shop or whatever
I'm like and it's because no one's you
know it's because almost you know in
both senses intercom oh I see maybe
you've been a bit too demure or
standoffish okay come to us when you're
ready but we're not coming to you
you know like I like maybe that suits
the Brawn maybe it doesn't but like but
I could see how it's a challenge on your
so well cuz I mean in large part we're
just making stuff that we want
mm-hm and at least me I don't really
consume the super sales forward content
and even like blogs and podcasts that
are all about throwing their brand down
your throat I just like I'm not into it
I unsubscribe I just get out of it
so for me that's a thing but then on the
other hand I'm like okay there has to be
some growth strategy here but you
preciseiy you're the director of
marketing you didn't want to think that
you're right like so I like yeah it's a
really interesting spectrum right that I
often talk to people go under like you
know in the early stage say to do a
startup like if you were to say like um
you say let's say Y Combinator's product
is is the actual incubator right it's in
like it's it's it's cash for equity in
high potential startups if you were to
literally only invest on making sure
that everyone knows about that you'll
become known as a type of banker someday
like you're like are Y comma at the
financial model you know like and if you
really drive for that then what happens
is everyone forgets about all everything
else and and you don't appeal to people
under any other grounds whatsoever it's
just a go if you need money go to them
and that's actually not your message
right oh no it would be a commodity
which you get worst case precisely right
so and your and your value property K
for 8% or something right like yeah Anna
and then then the very second you
quantify data someone else come in say
we're 60 K for 7% don't know you've lost
a fight because you've made it so
quantifiable you've taken brand and all
that other stuff out of it that you've
basically sowed the seeds your own
destruction on the other extreme right
you can have like Y common areas their
global phenomena right like we're where
we barely tell you that we do anything
other than it just evoke magnificence
and like the the challenge there is then
like you know you know you're so
abstract that no one actually realizes
you what you do and like you're genuine
like your money like big brands that
have become they've spread themselves
I'm like I hate to pick on people
I hate become big brands but they stand
like he thinks someone's a huge
Consulting houses or whatever like or
some of its huge software firms like no
one really knows exactly what they do
but like put every knows who they are
right and I think that's that's no use I
deride becoming one of the biggest
brands in the world that no one can I
kind of explained for a moment what the
hell you do they're becoming one of
these people that's so associated with
your product that you can never do
anything else except for your product
yeah absolutely that and like so an
example I see is like you know someone
pages me like a start-up and that's like
oh we're we truck tickets for help desks
and what are you called take a trucker
and I'm like okay you do realize that
you're basically saying over the next 10
years you're only ever going to track
tickets and stuff it's not like are you
comfortable having like I can see how
the value is strong for you today
because no one's gonna ask you about
this ticket record here right and no
one's gonna take a tracker what's do it
wait a minute sell but like you've sold
yourself the seeds of your own sort of
destruction because you can't grow that
brand in any way you know it's you know
if you're like you know hotels calm or
do you do oh okay that's cool but now
you see our hotels are come and we also
sell flights and you're like huh yeah
totally so like it's it's hard to expand
a brand that has a high degree of
specificity it's hard to convert a brand
that is a high degree of ambiguity and
that's the sort of spectrum that we
dance in you know and what are those how
do you connect those dots effectively
and in a way that makes sense for your
users or would-be users yeah so like
first of all is it's like finding the
point on the spectrum that you're
comfortable it like is in so like
intercom you know at its core like you
know the idea is it's an intercom but
it's like you want to talk to people
right the logo is like eyes and a mouth
you can see and talk to your users and
and so on our mission is to make
internet business personal so that's
kind of like we've picked a relatively
abstract point is in another version of
introduced intercom what are being
called like website messenger you know
right and you know we would struggle
then to sell like marketing software or
something you know
so I think for us it's like finding the
the right level of abstraction such that
we can you know do the brand umbrella
can kind of cover all of your needs all
of the things you want you might want to
do and the to do that right like and
this is something otherwise all people
do you need to read up on concepts like
brand architecture and understand the
difference between an endorser brand and
like it's a primary brand and you know
what Simmons did a branded house and a
house of brands and all that sort of
stuff
that's all like really worth doing
and then when you've done all that then
it's like okay so for if you're
deliberately going for a slightly bigger
tailor you know you you could be selling
like cheap flights calm or you could say
a v8 you'll take you to your destination
right and you have to like work you know
so a VA it's a hard I want to convert
cheap flights comms I hard want to
expound so you find your level and then
it's that tells you the starting point
in your funnel so our starting point is
anyone who has an internet business
right so so from not point to do job one
create an audience of people who are
interested in internet businesses under
problems and then job two is then sort
of specify in to the problems in your
home so so we primarily solve go to
market to type problems so it's like
sales marketing and support software
that's basically where intercom plays so
talk about the problems for those people
and we also talk about product problems
just cuz it's an easier because
basically in early-stage startups
everyone does everything so it's usually
a product person is also to market so M
so then we sort of start building the
first of all grow the audience then you
get this specificity by like talking
about specific problems on my way I say
talking and my mind goes to content but
it's worth thing this can be media
campaigns it can be awed by as it can be
sponsorships of events so think they're
basically pushing at the messages that
you want and ultimately get people to
the landing pages that represent the
things that you want to sell and then
obviously try and convert to more and
start talking to them and say hey what
were you shopping for like yeah this is
what probably this thing we did most in
ear today is intercom with someone
signed up but like out of curiosity what
did you think you were getting when you
bought an intercom and it was a great
question because because it helps us
unravel a lot of stuff like I see
someone had a question here but yeah
well David Confed asked about like why
did we split up our product into like we
used to beat up just one intercom ting
and there were a suite of things that
was entirely result of this it was it
was basically realizing we were selling
intercom but people were buying a
helpdesk or people were crying and I'm
like this is back to Karen's pointer
like bill we sell so you built so we're
like okay some people love intercom
because it's a great way to support your
customers and that's one of the most
visible to use cases I'm not that's why
you see it in other sites and when we
set when we meet them again on our
website we need to let them find the
thing they want so if job one of that is
import a CSV of all your targets and
we'll set ups
campaign said like dude I came here to
what for me right now yeah it's like you
need to talk to those folks over
marketing I'm just trying to support
people yeah so what we actually did what
we ended up doing as we split up our
product into like into the things we
knew it was used for which is primarily
supporting your customers and marketing
to your customers and that led us be
really more much more specific about
when we could pitch intercom and then we
could say here's when intercom does for
support teams and then if you sign up
for the support product we could say
okay here's the onboarding steps for
support and we wouldn't talk to
marketing at all because you're not a
marketer in the old world we were trying
to like charge you and get you to use
everything at the same time so we seemed
kind of expensive and also we were
trying to like what was it like a
12-step configuration because we hate
you hot to do everything and that
actually made sense when we're talking
to two persons startups and stuff way
back right but these days were generally
talking to functions not whole companies
and so so we have to kind of help people
find the exact sort of their own home
within the product so that's where we
split the product up and that's and that
that goes back to that question oh but
as we got more specific we have to get
you know how give every single person
who's shopping for a different thing
their own tailored experience to find
the exact party intercom they need yeah
and so when someone is shopping on your
site would have been the things that
have been most effective in actually
converting them right there we we
haven't done a great degree of degree of
like abt I mean address a certain amount
of your listeners are going to hear
while green buttons work better than red
but like a 400 yeah yeah I think the
stuff that we found useful has been
unbundling our pitch into the specific
ways in which it's bought that's been
huge and you can actually see like if
you look at say I think stripes on pages
is that pretty well these days like
they're that they can sell your
marketplace or they can still use Sigma
or radar or connector and similarly we
were like you know are you in the sales
and marketing started your green support
work and if you're in sales and
marketing will will get you at a pitch
that works for us now if you're in
support we'll talk to you about like why
you should love your users and how will
increase your FPS and all that
making those sort of switches rather
than trying to sell this holistic
mishmash duh it's kind of un open to say
one size fits known phenomena right like
um so I think getting more specific and
getting us a website that enables us to
be more specific about our value
propositions for different people was
probably like the biggest useful thing
the second biggest usally went down I
think was like tailoring and iterating
the hell out of our actual onboarding
for the use cases you're buying so like
all customers you know all paths don't
necessarily have to go to the same
direction for somebody to become a
customer of yours for some people they
might wanna install a JavaScript order
people might want to just import they're
your customers and start from there and
we've we've had great success kind of
finding the right ways in which the
right types of people can get on board
it to be successful with intercom we you
know we've had I'd say we probably over
over the years of experimentation before
double dare traveled our actual
conversion rate treating as well yeah
how many times have you iterated on the
sounds not enough okay yeah not enough
honestly I'm I thought it was something
I was seeing everything we've been
talking with the messenger a bit lately
and yeah it's weird how like audio
doesn't get discussed in in a software
enough because it's not part of the
wireframes if you know I mean it it
doesn't you know like you don't have the
same producer in the room with the
designer that's just the icon first yeah
yeah it's how exactly I think precisely
am so no you're totally correct it's
something that's on my mind and this
there's a general sort of tension
between like hmmm how identifiable we
want intercom to be versus house how
customizable it is that's another
spectrum you have to work out reviews
it's like people often want to customize
the intercom launcher and well we
generally support them in doing that but
anyone who customized a messenger we
sort of support through nuna but then
they want to customize specific bit so
it's barely intercom anymore and at some
point you're kind of like whoa I didn't
realize I care about this but we
actually do have some beliefs about head
which might make it terrible yeah there
are many of sites where you're like
where the hell is that sound coming from
why are there bells ringing random what
why is there a video autoplay and all
that sort of [ __ ] right yeah yeah that's
sourced so I'm curious about you in the
future
mm-hm what's coming next for you as your
role and intercom changes
I would guess you know we're out of
scale now were in general as startups
grow you move from like Swiss Army
knives to scalpels right so yeah so and
I was hysterically like a Swiss Army
knife with one particularly pointy blade
for product but that was useful because
I meant I could go and bounce around and
take the take on different portfolios of
things and generally bring them up to
some level and then learn enough and
then we could bring in somebody who
actually knows what you mean and that
person would inherit you haven't burned
the house down yeah yeah and maybe I've
got the bait and maybe I've put out the
immediate fires and I've sort of set the
stage for like someone to come in and do
some real work and but I think we're out
of scale now or maybe I'm necessarily
optimistic but I think we have like you
know good people leading all the
functions so I think there might now be
a time for me to maybe retreat to an
area of actual ability yeah which maybe
looks like me going back to the product
order but we'll see I mean intercom has
never failed to surprise me with the
areas it the ways in which you can you
know produce new problems for me let's
say yeah so then what if you weren't
working on intercom what would you work
on I did on today's votes before and you
referred to it earlier um there are
here's two problems I think about alone
one of them is simple its soccer is
without the biggest sport on the planet
I'm sorry Super Bowl sons it's huge
and it is literally the sport technology
is left behind I think there's a lot of
reasons for a lot of my kind of societal
a lot of cultural um you know nerds and
sports day military career American
soccer tend not to go together
I was example okay sorry about the
reason so sorry everyone
yeah
so what does a huge opportunity there oh
yeah piracy and soccer is I would say I
like the levels pre iTunes if you
remember in the music industry right
like do our electric there isn't
equivalent of because I there are many
of them and no one's doing anything is
solved solving it would be a very
complex piece of work because a lot of
it is in programming a lot of it would
be actual code but there will be a lot
of deals and on the best day actually
don't yet ownerships and lots of [ __ ]
right and it's not a guarantee like ESPN
will get their [ __ ] together or
something like that right but like I can
imagine like a Spotify for soccer
writers in hey I wanna watch that game
happened last night I should be able to
watch it I'll pay but it's not even
possible for me to watch a game that
happened yesterday it's just not
possible like literally not possible so
that's how backwards it is and I think
that needs to get fixed so thanks so
much it fixed that I think the
opportunity is big the markets huge so
that's one another one is I think no one
has really taken a harsh look at like
let's just say pensions and retirement
funds there I thought like is in there's
a company in New York called lemonade
that took a really really nice approach
to insurance for property it's a boss
basically you talk to it and you can get
you can literally insure your house in
New York in like five minutes just true
you know chatbot basically I think
that's an example of like tackling a
real what why has historically a lot of
paperwork and a lot of [ __ ] around
and turning into a relatively simple
flow and making it work I think that
model and I'm not saying chatbots aren't
sitting here so much as drastic
simplification as sitting and what the
Q&A maybe suggest that a chatbot might
be like charming is a way to do it or
like you at least unique from a brand
perspective but I think there's a lot of
areas like that you know where car
insurance is another obvious iteration
but like anything to do with like a
mortgage application like you know like
I think there's a lot of areas that are
rich for like drastic simplification
that people turn a little bit away from
because of what Paul Graham would call
like to schlep work started like you
know it's it's easier to build a recipe
out parentally done it is to go and talk
to banks to it saying I want to reduce
mortgage
creation to like tree tops you know
but I you know I dare like obvious areas
what I would have to offer a prone to
say like I don't feel a drastic passion
and any of those myself but there's
something I could get excited about when
I say I don't feel a drastic passion
what I really mean it's like remember I
talked earlier but I coming up strong
vision for the space and all that like I
can jump to like a chatbot for like you
know for mortgage applications but I
actually need to take a step back and be
like what do I actually believe her
that's that it's that I believe I guess
maybe like the finance should be
liberated of the bureaucracy that's been
an inherent in the industry for so long
you know but like I need to go and draw
that whole landscape and then be like
how am i excited to put another decade
in my life onto something like this yeah
because like intercoms you know or the
intercom story has taken a quarter my
life so far and I've enjoyed it I like
still you know if I stood if I was ever
to do something else you know I now know
how many good how high a filter I have
to apply in order to say yes right but
it's a huge problem I mean I suppose
many of these are rare in your lifetime
but they're gigantic big here yet big
rare that's that's a great point I think
a great application of that yeah yeah
and I think the the incentives also
aren't aligned right like the companies
are incentivized to make it complicated
because they exist on fees I think
that's why Vanguard was such a success
right yeah ready index fund yeah you're
done yeah you're totally correct yeah so
like I think yet there's a there's a
simplification model there and the
efficiencies you get by not having to go
through all the bureaucracy you could
share that saving with the user in a
sense yeah I did like dude there is an
opportunity there I'm very confident of
that like but yeah the doors like
there's a bit of the calculus you'd have
to do to work out like you know where
you gonna make your money what's the
best way to do it etcetera I think
that's a whole category of startups that
are just now in the past couple years
being attacked yeah because in the past
was like I'm gonna just make developer
tools and stay it's just it's just me
and my editor it's a lot easier what is
interesting is the people Pro best
position to do it don't necessarily have
the programming skills so like this
doesn't know I could imagine a world
where like you some universities this
area we're gonna have our MBAs meet our
engineers and we're gonna troll a lot of
problems near we're gonna see what the
[ __ ] happens and I could see that
working I don't you know it wouldn't
really have I think the last question I
have for you is
you've written all this content over the
years you've you know done podcast inter
comes like all over the place what's the
favorite your favorite thing that you've
ever made like me I mean like so every
I'm supposed to say intercom I can hear
my [ __ ] comms team in here already
blog posts a podcast yeah do you like
intercom yeah for sure okay so let's
just take that off to have I guess for
me person isn't the thing that will be a
desk trainer production of sorts I
didn't know it at the time but I gave a
seven minute talk in Boston maybe five
years ago six years ago called product
strategy means saying no goddamn and
it's kind of being like I'd say probably
like that's definitely most popular talk
I've ever given because at seven minutes
and I think it was funny it was doing in
the style where like the slide no
control over the slides and they change
every 15 seconds I was one of those so
yeah and and so I kind of forces you to
be a little bit dynamic and entertaining
but it came out pretty well it was [ __ ]
and rehearsal I was convinced it's gonna
be terrible
but it came out pretty well when I
actually performed it for real and I
think it kind of it you know it raised
my profile substantially as a sort of
public speaker and I kind of sowed the
seeds of a lot of future things like I
got to speak out like you know eight
tears in person events and so since then
but um but I think that was probably
that's really the one that I looked back
and sort of Chocola bit because it
wasn't like I had I intended that to
happen but am but kind of forced into a
corner like I've always been my my
makeup is that I'm better under time
pressure than I am under likely like
longitudinal sort of abstract projects
whatever and that was when I was [ __ ] I
have to do this team the next see my
girls turned it on I kind of backed into
a corner that was what I produced and I
look back at that now and I kind of I
found memories of it that's cool yeah
we'll link up to it then in the podcast
drew the script is a blog there's a
supporting blog post as well yeah it was
definitely similar to some of the more
fun stuff I did awesome man
well thanks for coming in thank you so
much Greg for a great view
you